en este vídeo me gustaría tratar la
diferencia acerca de una deuda de una
persona común y corriente por ejemplo la
deuda de una casa que comúnmente se
llama hipoteca a comparación de la deuda
de una empresa supongamos en esta
ocasión que a mí me presta el banco un
millón de pesos el concepto de este
préstamo la verdad no me importa lo que
me importa es que voy a hacer pagos
mensuales de esta deuda de un millón de
pesos y otra cosa que sería muy buena
aclarar desde un principio es que
nosotros vamos a tener la misma cantidad
de dinero que pagar durante cada mes
ahora bien si analizamos cada uno de los
pagos que vamos a tener este pago va a
constar de dos partes vamos hacer un
cierto pago a una cantidad de interés y
un cierto pago a mi cantidad de deuda
que yo tengo por ejemplo si realizamos
el primer pago que vamos a hacer este va
a constar de dos partes de pagar una
cierta cantidad de interés que por
cierto en el primer pago que va a ser la
cantidad de interés que vamos a pagar es
casi la totalidad del pago mientras que
la otra parte va a ser la deuda original
que nosotros tenemos que para fines
prácticos vamos a llamarle deuda
principal y lo que quiero que se den
cuenta es que en este primer pago la
cantidad que vamos a pagar desde
principal es muy pequeña ahora bien ya
pagamos algo de la deuda principal por
lo tanto en nuestro siguiente pago vamos
a pagar menos intereses y un poquito más
de la deuda principal por lo tanto para
seguir pagando en nuestra hipoteca lo
que va a pasar es lo siguiente en el
siguiente pago vamos a pagar una
cantidad de interés la cual va a ser
menor a la cantidad del primer pago y en
esta mensualidad también vamos a pagar
una cierta cantidad de deuda principal
la cual va a ser mayor a la cantidad que
pagamos en el primer pago y como todos
los pagos son iguales entonces así se va
a mantener esta relación es decir para
el tercer pago de nuestra hipoteca lo
que va a suceder es lo siguiente vamos a
pagar una menor cantidad de interés
mientras que vamos a pagar una mayor
cantidad de la deuda principal y así va
a ser sucesivamente a lo largo de todas
las mensualidades que hayan acordado
hasta que llegamos a la última en la
cual para finalizar de pagar nuestra
hipoteca vamos a tener el mismo pago sin
embargo en esta ocasión lo que vamos a
hacer es pagar muy pero muy poco interés
es decir una cantidad muy pequeña y
vamos a tener que pagar una gran
cantidad de la deuda principal que
nosotros tenemos entonces miren aquí
está la pequeña cantidad que tenemos que
pagar de interés esto debido a que ya
que así pagamos toda la deuda principal
porque recuerden que el interés no los
van a comprar de la cantidad que debemos
y en una segunda parte de nuestro pago
va a consistir en una gran cantidad del
pago de nuestra deuda principal y con
esto acabamos de pagar nuestra deuda y
ya con esto nuestra deuda está cerrada y
es así como funciona la tradicional tasa
hipotecaria
ahora bien vamos a ver qué es lo que
sucede cuando una compañía o una empresa
pide un cierto préstamo vamos a suponer
también que este préstamos de un millón
de pesos bueno cuando una empresa pide
un cierto préstamo no va a suceder lo
mismo que pasa cuando nosotros pedimos
un cierto préstamo es decir no va a
pagar una cierta cantidad de interés y
una cierta cantidad de la deuda
principal aquí lo que va a pasar es que
siempre va a pagar una misma cantidad de
interés durante todo el tiempo que dure
ese préstamo es decir que si las deudas
a pagar durante diez años
pago en el segundo pago en el tercer
pago en cada uno de los pagos va a pagar
la misma cantidad y va a ser solamente
de interés en el primer pago interés en
el segundo pago interés y así
sucesivamente durante cada uno de los
pagos que va a ser durante esos diez
años y cuando lleguemos al último pago
va a pagar su cierta cantidad de interés
aquí está el penúltimo pago que es
interés y en el último pago además de
tener su parte de interés va a tener que
pagar toda la cantidad de dinero que le
prestaron voy a ponerlo de otro color
toda la cantidad de deuda principal que
le hicieron en un principio es decir el
millón de pesos lo va a tener que pagar
de un solo golpe en el último pago y es
justo por esta razón que muchas empresas
se vuelven a endeudar porque si tienen
el dinero pues lo pagan pero si no tiene
el dinero lo que van a hacer es buscar
la forma de pagar este préstamo y
entonces para pagar esta deuda lo que
van a hacer es conseguir un préstamo
nuevo ya sea del mismo banco o ya sea de
otro banco para poder cubrir esta deuda
por lo tanto van a pedir un nuevo
préstamo y otra vez con sus respectivos
intereses y con ese préstamo van a pagar
su deuda inicial y otra vez a empezar
ojo si lo piden a otro banco o este
mismo banco no forzosamente van a tener
los mismos intereses puede ser que la
cantidad de intereses que van a tener
que dar en cada pago sea mayor y bueno
otra cosa que hay que analizar es el
convenio eso es independientemente de la
cantidad de interés o de la forma de
interés que tú veas a pagar el convenio
es la forma en la que el banco se va a
asegurar que la empresa va a pagar esa
deuda y que no corre riesgo en perder su
dinero o en dado caso de que tu empresa
no pueda pagar el préstamo entonces
pedir un préstamo nuevo para pagar el
préstamo inicial y todo esto es para que
el banco tenga un control de que no va a
perder su dinero pero lo que quiero que
se den cuenta es que es muy distinto a
las hipotecas usuales